this is the most exciting GPU launch in
an age and I've got the sapphire Nitro
plus RX 7800 XT to take a quick look at
Sapphire yes
[Music]
so the 7800 if you are not familiar I
did a separate review of the AMD
reference version and the launch and all
the stuff around the launch this is
rdna3 it has 16 gigabytes of vram this
is meant to be five year card the card
that is accessible for a long long time
like you buy it and you use it for two
three four five years or you know the
car that's at the affordable price point
the most performance per dollar price
point that's what this is meant to be
and mostly it delivers and we'll take a
look at that in terms of the benchmarks
in terms of the build and the fit and
finish this feels like a top tier card
like you know the 1700 is sort of the
middle of the road card it's not the
least expensive and it is by far not the
most expensive in fact you can spend
three times as much on a GPU that
wouldn't deliver three times the
performance
but it's a large card it is fully every
bit of three slots it also has a three
slot bracket at the end which you should
be careful of because
a lot of the time builds in different
cases will make physical accommodations
for two brackets even though there is
room for three brackets worth of stuff
especially if you're using this uh you
know in a bottom slot you're doing a
threadripper build uh something like
that and so you're hanging off the end
of the motherboard things in like the
fractal defined XL case where you've got
the extra slot at the bottom that kind
of thing wouldn't work for a true three
slot bracket but it does give Sapphire
the ability to build in Full full length
GPU bracket support they also made their
GPU taller so if you're in a case like
the lien Li 011 Dynamic it can make
builds in that case a little more
Troublesome but they have recessed the
power connector which is the thing that
you usually run into the problem and so
because the power connector is recessed
even though the card is super tall it
sort of gives you the best of both
worlds it gives you the best shot at
this GPU actually working in some of
those cases where the the motherboard
tray depth is is not as much but you
know it is a full three slot bracket at
the end something to consider when
you're doing your build it is a full
you know metal back plate and metal
support we've also got a GPU anti-sag
support bracket built on this side as
well so mechanically this is a
significant chunker of a card
I like that it actually feels like the
toxic Sapphire toxic they're sort of
their their most famous highest and
Ultra Premium card and this sort of
feels like a toxic card from a couple of
generations ago or three three four more
than a couple of generations ago it's a
very very beefy card we have three large
and very quiet fans we've got a little
bit of pass-through cooling on the end
of the card here
but mostly the card is shorter and
thicker for a 7 800 class GPU again this
is the middle of the road GPU they're
not dumping 600 watts of power into this
this is kind of Overkill I mean look
we've got five heat pipes coming out the
end of the heatsink on the end here this
is just
it's just Madness but as we'll see in
the benchmarks the madness is perhaps
Justified we've also got two eight pin
power connectors the my favorite thing
about this GPU is that you can have a
normal power supply on your computer 700
Watts 750 watts 800 watts all of that is
fine and will work great with this GPU
pretty much no matter what your build is
except for maybe the highest end you
know threadripper or you're doing
something off label for just a normal
desktop build I've only got a 700 watt
power supply of two eight pin connectors
this is the card that can do 60fps at 4K
even before we get into the whole frame
generation upscaling technology stuff
it is a really nice attractive build
I'll also mention that it does have a
bios switch which is awesome if you're a
Linux user and you're flashing bioses
are trying different stuff you've always
got a recovery path as long as you only
use one of your bios for experimentation
and the other bios for Recovery very
nice we've also got a an RGB out header
and a fan in header the display
connectors on this GPU are a little
unusual you have two HDMI 2.1 and two
DisplayPort 2.1 so dual DisplayPort dual
HDMI if wishes were horses I would have
preferred just adding an HDMI so you had
five connectors any four of which were
usable but hey it's a 7800 class GPU and
they're trying to make the GPU not cost
significantly more than the AMD
reference version as compared with the
AMD reference version this is a
physically much larger card in fact the
reference version of the AMD 7800 is the
smallest to 7 800 that I've seen it
would fit in a lot of very very small
builds whereas this is basically your
your high tier GPU from last generation
three slots truly three slots needs
Cooling and basically always accept
power so
something to consider when you're
working on your build this GPU is also
an excellent choice for Linux
workstations because the extreme Maximum
Overkill and cooling means that this GPU
is going to run cool all of the time
even when you're playing games the
temperatures are really
pretty impressive so
let's take a look at the performance so
for Borderlands 3 the name of the game
here is to look for improvements over
reference and starting it off at 4K
we're seeing a pattern a little bit of a
pattern that emerges at 4K but is maybe
not elsewhere so Borderlands 3 it's an
older title and already the 7800 XT
Nitro plus Edition is pulling a little
bit ahead and both are one percent lows
and our overall average frame rate
nice job but we dropped down to 1080P
and while we get a higher average frame
rate something weird was going on and
our one percent lows were significantly
lower now the 7800 XT reference and the
Nitro plus were tested at different
times and this is after I was
troubleshooting an F1 2023 issue so I
think this was because the state of the
system was different during the
reference card testing and the
Borderlands 3 testing but uh I didn't
have a lot of time with this card so uh
things have to go on we saw that at
1440p so I feel like this is a system
specific issue and I didn't see this in
any other games so I think this is
probably just something down to the
system and not anything with the
hardware itself
for the Callisto protocol at 4K 115 FPS
the one percent of 0.1 percent lows I
mean that's just Callisto protocol this
is the 4K High preset over 100 FPS on
a you know five six hundred dollar class
GPU at launch very impressive
221 FPS at 1080p with one percent lows
staying around 60.
1440p again one percent low sticking
pretty close to 60 180 FPS 1440p is
probably where I would play Callisto
protocol or 4K like a medium high as
opposed to the high preset
cyberpunk 2077 at 4K 84 FPS very very
respectable and a very respectable
performance bump over the reference
editions just barely outside of margin
of error but the increased clock speed
of the sapphire Nitro plus is is
appreciable here you can get even a
little more than this if you're willing
to overclock
but these are the out-of-the-box numbers
in terms of performance
193 versus 195 basically margin of error
for 1080 and 1440 143 versus 146.
for fire strike it does make a pretty
significant difference I mean 49 000
overall score versus 47 000 for the
reference Edition you can tell that
Sapphire has done something different
with this card over reference
shadow of the Tomb Raider at 4K
basically within margin of error in
terms of differences 251 versus 245 okay
at 1080p I am seeing a little bit of an
uplift outside of margin of error 178
versus a 183 a 1440p yeah that's
probably down to
um that's probably down to improvements
in the card as well but it's kind of
close
18 000 versus
sapphires made some improvements to
their card this is a pretty strong
showing overall and there we are there's
the reason that you buy this card
temperature and Noise
we've got a 15 degree C Improvement
average over the reference version of
this card the sapphire doesn't believe
in running the card hot because
that's just how Sapphire rolls now
there's not a huge difference between
our hot spot temperatures among the 7
800 models that I'm testing
but even that shows a pretty significant
improvement over the reference model but
still how I test this is I run Callisto
protocol for a very very long time on a
benchmark Loop basically because
Callisto protocol is basically on The
Struggle Bus when it comes to uh the
high presets as evidenced by the one
percent lows and everything else is it
or we GPU limited or CPU limited it's
kind of a real world gaming test as
opposed to an artificial Benchmark for
your GPU which is just gonna run your
GPU at some ridiculous temperature all
the time this card was also surprisingly
quiet under this test if you're playing
a game with your desktop on your desktop
it's going to be much less noticeable in
terms of fan noise and everything else
over the hum of the rest of your system
giant heat pipes notwithstanding
probably something to do with sapphire
design
Sapphire also has one unique software
trick up their sleeve called Trix boost
a Trix boost is a neat technology I
wouldn't exactly call it resolution
scaling but it lets you render the game
part of the game not the HUD part of the
game at a lower resolution and get a
performance benefit but it's not hard
and fast like you don't render 1440p and
upscale it to 4K you can render it some
in between resolution between 1440 and
4K some games have added this kind of
thing natively but Trix boost lets you
do this
basically with any game sometimes with
side effects sometimes not but generally
Sapphire is doing a pretty good job here
making that work for their gpus overall
the verdict here this is a superior
cooling solution this is probably a
five-year solution in terms of GPU
engineering and a little bit of an
overclock out of the box definitely
helps at higher resolutions lower
resolutions not so much because you're
probably limited by other things that
are going on with the system but higher
resolutions yeah for sure definitely in
general now and in the past I've liked
Sapphire Hardware engineering this card
is no exception I think they've probably
over built it for what the 7800 is I
mean I get why they made the choices
they made and overall so far in my
testing it's a pretty solid card I'm
going to try to squeeze in some Linux
testing with this card before I have to
send it back because I do think the 7800
series is going to be the the every man
Enthusiast like I don't want to spend
too much money on my GPU but I kind of
want a nice GPU GPU for Linux and
Sapphire generally on Linux it's been a
pretty solid option but you'll have to
wait for another video for that I'm one
of those level one I'm signing out you
can find me in the level one forums
[Music]